notre père vient de mourir et sa
dernière volonté et que ses fils
assistent à ses funérailles t'es pas
obligé d'y aller il est mort
il en sera jamais rien d'une tendresse
débordante tu le sais ça
ces dernières volonté votre père a fait
une ultime de monde que vous creusiez
satombe
quoi
notre père nous en a fait voir de toutes
les couleurs
pardonner sa soulage
je vais vous montrer le cercueil que
votre père avait choisi
c'est l'homme le plus radan j'ai jamais
vu
[Musique]
ça fait combien de temps que vous
connaissez l'affaire pendant quelques
temps on a été un manque
il était quel genre de père la pire
sorte c'est encore comme un poids sur ma
poitrine
pardonner sa soulage
ça va les garçons je vais vous présente
mon fils Simon Raymond
errer tes frères
et moi on vient du chaos
son père était un monstre avec lui et
puis on répète les mêmes schémas on
n'est pas obligé
le petit on était comme des frères
siamois
rien que le fait de côtoyer l'autre
ravive la douleur
je veux savoir ce que ça fait c'est
derrière nous
j'ai peur que ça me [ __ ] en l'air
accompagne-moi
[Musique]
ok
il va te falloir autre chose qu'un trou
dans la terre pour te sortir le vieux de
la tête
[Musique]